[Musica]
[Applauso]
questa foglia non è una semplice foglia
Più che altro è un simbolo magari per
alcuno potrebbe essere un simbolo
negativo per altri un simbolo positivo
ma tutti quanti guardandola sappiamo
perfettamente di quello che stiamo
parlando e se un giorno questa foglia
diventasse il futuro simbolo della moda
sostenibile
Eh sì perché la canapa di questo stiamo
parlando è una pianta che ci permette di
ottenere delle fibre tessili con un
bassissimo impatto
ambientale Peccato però che al giorno
d'oggi sia Praticamente inutilizzata nel
mondo della
moda dobbiamo fare una distinzione molto
importante tra canapa e e
cannabis Perché giustamente Qualcuno
potrebbe dire È ovvio che che è
inutilizzata questa pianta è illegale in
tantissimi paesi del mondo il consumo
delle infiorescenze di questa pianta è
illegale in tantissimi paesi del mondo è
ovvio che non viene utilizzata dobbiamo
fare questa distinzione tra canapa e
cannabis dal punto di vista botanico
scientifico sono la stessa pianta il
nome è cannabis sativa
però con canapa si fa riferimento a
quella pianta che produce delle
inflorescenze senza THC senza la
sostanza psicoattiva mentre con cannabis
la pianta che produce delle
infiorescenze con il THC quindi quella
utilizzata in ambito medico e ricreativo
Sono due cose molto
diverse noi oggi ci concentriamo sulla
canapa quindi sulla pianta che produce
delle infiorescenze senza il THC e come
detto prima è praticamente inutilizzata
nel nel mondo della moda Infatti ad oggi
nel mondo si producono solo
250.000 tonnellate di fibre di canapa
come solo tantissimo 250.000 tonnellate
di fibre di canapa in realtà questo
numero rappresenta solo lo
0,2% di tutte le fibre prodotte a
livello globale per capire ancora meglio
facciamo questo esempio se tutte le
fibre Sono all'interno di un pacco da
mezzo kg di fusilli le fibre di canapa
sono rappresentate solo ed
esclusivamente da un singolo fusillo
quindi possiamo dire che sono
completamente
inutilizzate ma prima di capire il
motivo per cui dovremmo utilizzare
questa pianta come fonte di fibre
sostenibili cerchiamo di fare un passo
indietro nel tempo perché forse non
tutti sanno che questa Fibra è stata
ampiamente utilizzata nel passato
Infatti arriva dall'Oriente e già in
Cina migliaia di anni fa si utilizzava
proprio per produrre i
vestiti poi chiaramente durante il corso
dei decenni dei millenni si è espansa in
tutto il mondo e ha trovato tantissime
altre applicazioni come ad
esempio formare le pagine della prima
Bibbia di Gutenberg o
ancora le vele e le funi di Cristoforo
Colombo erano fatte con la
canapa addirittura noi in Italia tra gli
anni 40 e 50 del 9 eravamo i secondi
produttori A livello mondiale di
canapa Peccato però che poi Con
l'avvento della plastica e di tutta una
serie di leggi che ne hanno limitato la
diffusione sappiamo com'è andata a
finire e il mercato è andato via via
scemando si stima però che entro il
2030 il mercato della Canapa
raddoppierà quindi c'è una buona
prospettiva Ma torniamo al cuore del
Disc corso perché dovremmo
utilizzarla coltivare la canapa ha senso
soprattutto dal punto di vista
ambientale e adesso vediamo il perché in
cinque punti Il primo è l'assorbimento
di anidride carbonica come tutte le
piante assorbe anidride carbonica CO2
immaginiamoci di avere due campi da
calcio uno coltivato con la canapa e uno
coltivato in qualche modo con una
foresta tropicale non so come si possa
fare però immagini amoco alzi la mano
chi pensa che la foresta tropicale
assorba più CO2 della
Canapa Ok interessante In realtà io
prima di cominciare questo speech
Pensavo che la foresta tropicale fosse
più assorbente diciamo Ma in realtà la
quantità di anidride carbonica è la
stessa 10 tonnellate di anidride
carbonica canapa e foresta tropicale Ma
infatti la domanda non è Quanta ma in
quanto tempo la canapa assorbe questa
quantità di CO2 in solo 5 mesi mentre la
foresta tropicale in almeno 10 anni
quindi la canapa assorbe tantissima CO2
in pochissimo tempo questo era il primo
punto secondo punto molto importante è
l'acqua per produrre 1 kg di cotone
classico cotone servono di media 10.000
l d'acqua per produrre 1 kg di fibre di
canapa solo solo 2700 solo perché
comunque stiamo parlando di grandi
quantità di acqua ma rispetto al cotone
Siamo meno di 1 terz quindi l'impronta
idrica l'impronta idrica della Canapa è
sicuramente inferiore rispetto a quella
del cotone e questo è un plus Terzo
punto velocità la canapa possiamo
considerarla come una pianta autonoma ha
bisogno di poche risorse terreno luce
acqua una volta che ha queste tre cose
lei cresce autonomamente e in fretta
All'inizio la crescita è lenta ma poi ha
un boom nelle successive 5-6 settimane e
può arrivare ad un'altezza di
addirittura 5
m e questo è fondamentale se Dobbiamo
considerare anche gli aspetti economici
non possiamo pensare di produrre dei
vestiti a partire da delle piante che ci
mettono un'eternità a
crescere quarto punto pesticidi O meglio
prodotti
fitosanitari la canapa ha bisogno di
veramente pochissimi di questi pesticidi
non ha tanti pr
naturali a differenza del cotone che
invece consuma tra il 5 e il 10% di
tutti i pesticidi prodotti a livello
mondiale e sia la produzione che
l'utilizzo di pesticidi Ha un impatto
ambientale quindi essere
indipendenti dai pesticidi Anche questo
è un Plus e è da considerare come un
impatto ambientale molto basso quinto e
ultimo punto la biodiversità il ciclo di
fioritura della Canapa avviene
solitamente tra luglio e settembre e
nello stesso periodo si ha una
scarsissima produzione di Polline da
parte delle altre piante e qui subentra
la canapa lei invece produce tantissimo
polline e questo è fondamentale per gli
insetti in più le piante che sono molto
grandi possono fornire riparo per alcuni
uccelli e in più i semi sono anche
alimento per alcuni animali quindi
possiamo considerare la canapa come
l'amica della
biodiversità questi sono alcuni degli
aspetti fondamentali della Canapa che
può essere considerata come una pianta
che ci permette di ottenere delle fibre
sostenibili che ci permette di ottenere
dei vestiti durevoli nel tempo e i lati
negativi non può non può avere soltanto
lati positivi come tutte le cose ci sono
anche gli aspetti da considerare
negativi ci sono ad esempio i vestiti In
Canapa tendono a stropicciarsi molto
facilmente come la mia camicia di lino o
ancora la produzione è ancora molto
elaborata o molto costosa dato che la
diffusione è molto
limitata chi lavora nel settore però sa
benissimo che questi non sono dei veri e
propri aspetti
negativi il vero motivo per cui la
diffusione è ancora molto molto bassa è
l'enorme stereotipo che si è generato
dietro questa
pianta quindi Se vogliamo che la
direzione della moda sia la
sostenibilità dobbiamo cercare di
sradicare questo stereotipo tenere
separata la
canapa dalla cannabis sono la stessa
pianta ma sono due cose completamente
diverse e dobbiamo sforzarci di
immaginare questa foglia sette punte non
più come un simbolo negativo ma come un
simbolo di rinascita ecologico e della
moda
sostenibile
[Applauso]
Grazie